and here's daniel lynch who's had a
really bad time in his last two starts
in the first inning
in the second pitch of the game harrison
slaps it into left center field for a
base hit harrison with an aggressive
turn the helmet flies off and a good
start for the athletics
now the 2-2 pitch and that's high inside
but it hit him i think it hit him or hit
the bat and he was hit by it so marty
was hit and now the ace have two on and
nobody out
back to lynch
out at second and he gets a double play
lynch knew who he was working with in
case the ball came back to him with
communication before the pitch was
thrown and he knew exactly who to throw
to this is so important look at him
showing some athleticism throat wasn't
perfect but didn't matter they got to
and man did that help his pitch count in
the first year big time that's beautiful
just what he wanted
got him
big comeback for daniel lynch in a
scoreless first we have a starter that
threw under 20 pitches beautiful we'll
be taking on that man right there paul
blackburn making his sixth start of the
season here's the o2 pitch by blackburn
a curve swung on and missed mayor felix
so locked in
four hits two home runs five rbis and
four runs scored in this series
oh
left center field deep no way
[Music]
he's a machine
so salvador perez now 45 home runs he's
salvi strong and continues to do it
amazing the fans the fans are on their
feet
it's incredible they're all looking at
each other saying really did he just do
it in the first at-bat we got three more
bouts out of him this year or this today
hopefully 2-2 pitch
lined over shortstop into left center
field so manusy got a pitch up and lines
it to left center second hit off
blackburn
and he's going to drop one out into
shallow left center field monday will
turn and hold and the royals
keep charging in the bottom of the first
inning with two on and two out and two
home
runners go and that is a soft line drive
leaping up as elvis anders to grab it
side retired salvador perez with his
45th home run of the year royals leading
up
into right center
carrying with the wind and isbell makes
the play with his back up against the
wall
not as easy as it looked he had to run a
long way look he's playing to the pole
side and that balls goes up it good
backspin good carry wind blowing out
that way isbell never gave up on it i
love the peak to the wall right there
one little peeking twice he looked
that's even better and was able to pick
that ball up on a sunny day and lynch
says thank you very much save me some
extra base hits there
3-2
tries to change up that's not close it's
outside the a's got a lead-off walk as
they start the third trailing
two-nothing and josh harrison 0-2
in the hole and that's a base hit into
left field elvis anders rounds third
he's going to come in to score without a
throw and the a's are on the board rbi
single for harrison he has had a big
series
murrayfield has it and he's going to
throw to second nobody's there
everybody's safe the mistake by
maryfield he spun around and he threw it
to second but lopez just could not get
there so there was a sure out at first
and the royals did not take it so that's
a break for the athletics and now they
have a chance for a big inning
he thought about it but didn't go
tony randazzo was at third base today
and called a really good game behind the
plate and here comes mike matheny and
nick kenny to check on lynch after that
last pitch it's coming up piops has a
couple of choices right here he can put
all the pressure on his shoulders right
now and say man base is loaded nobody
out or he can decide that the pressure
is not all on him that this was started
with him in the bullpen and just be as
relaxed as he can and just try and get
through it as best he can
and it's a line drive caught by wet and
a double play
ding ding ding
whoa what a bonus pitch that was mario
for six in the series he does have a
sacrifice flying on the first pitch he
bounces it it goes off of o'hearn and
maryfield did not throw to first he
throws back to third and everybody's
safe the game is tied with maryfield all
he had to do was throw it to first base
and he would have got lowry and he never
did
pinder base hit left field
one run scores
canna coming home he's gonna score so
the a's come through big time
take advantage of some very poor
defensive play by the royals and now
it's four to two definitely needed that
chad pender needed that this lineup
needed that
kemp bunch it's a good one coming on his
wit flushes it over to o'hearn and they
get the runner that's a fine play by
wood merrifield we might have a check by
bob melvin he held up his right hand to
hold say the home plate umpire and right
now the crew chief tony randazzo is
going over and they will not review it
so that's a fine play by whit merrifield
hit well
and over marte
the a's
had the right idea that dozier would be
hitting it to left center field marte
was in the area but he didn't read it
well and it may have sailed over his
head anyway but hunter dozier has his
seventh extra base hit in his last seven
games one ball one strike sebastian
grounded out to third his first time up
lying to left and sinking and it's down
in front of canna
and the royals have their lead off man
on in the fifth
1-0 pitch and that's swung on by lopez
the ground but a second can they turn to
flip goes to elvis and back to first and
the a's get an inning ending four six
three double play that quickly the
bottom of the fifth comes to an end and
these lead the royals four to two
line and off of andrew's glove
sebastian rivero has a two-hit game and
the top of the order is coming up with
one out
and it is low for ball four and salvador
perez gets a chance to come up with two
on and two out
first pitch hit up the middle
scooped up by kemp who throws to first
perez is out so dio lascara gets a huge
out there and a nice two innings by
guerra 8th inning coming up he's leading
4-2
come on to see batting right-handed
lines one into right field there's a
solid hit
and the royals will have the tying run
at the plate here in the bottom of the
eighth alberto as he was coming to the
plate and waiting to be announced he
looked into the a's dugout and was
expecting bob melvin to pop up and make
a move but everyone's eyes turned to the
left field bullpen and there's nobody
warming up
and into the corner and that is a fair
ball
that ball just straightened out
and the royals will have runners at
second and third and one out
dozier chased it again on three pitches
chaffin strikes out dozier
3-2 pitch did he go yes the home plate
umpire called it himself nestor sia said
you went around and that's how the
inning ends so oliveira is shaking his
head no chaffin gets out of the jam and
the royals do not score so first and
third nobody out
and that one
past rivero runs going to come in to
score that's elvis andrews so it's five
to two
this one's driven right center
oliveira's back and it's over his head
off the wall kemp is gonna come in to
score harrison has a four hit game two
more rbis for josh harrison and now it's
six to two
seven rbis in this series for harrison
cannon bounces one slowly to the right
side dozier goes to second and they get
the out there so dozier goes to second
out there but harrison comes in to score
so canna's gonna get an rbi for the 60th
time this year as sergio romo comes out
of the ace pen one and one and a 445 era
olson's got it this should do it he'll
take it himself and that will do it
so the a's needed to win this series
and they do and now they will head to
anaheim hopefully with a little momentum
they need a big big weekend down in
southern california today paul blackburn
gets his first win here in 2021